if you think killing Eve hits it right
on the mark here are five other shows
totally worth checking out on this
week's binge guide fans love killing Eve
created by Phoebe Waller bridge for its
unexpected twist dark humor and great
acting so from hitman to assassins to
little drummer girls and fleabags here
are five other shows totally worth
binging starting with fleabag this
comedy series about a grief-stricken
young woman trying to cope with life in
London was also created by Waller bridge
and this time she stars in it with
back-to-back 100% certified fresh'
seasons and a whole trophy case full of
Emmys for things like Outstanding Comedy
Series writing and lead actress it's no
surprise the critics call fleabag a
clever wildly inventive comedy binging
this Amazon original series will take
you five and a half hours for all twelve
episodes and it'll be bloody worth it
trust me there's a hot priest in season
two
up next is this week's audience pick and
that's going to HBO's dark comedy very
following two certified fresh' seasons
with an average audience score of 90% a
third is in the works for this show
about a midwest hitman who gets caught
up in the LA theatre scene critics love
the pitch perfect way it balances
darkness with comedy which starts with
Bill Hader who shines in the lead
alongside a very strong supporting cast
led by the iconic Henry Winkler with a
pinch time of eight and a half hours
this is a fun easy watch that will give
you a greater appreciation of Bill Hader
and just maybe Peter actors marching its
way in as our under-the-radar pick it's
the little drummer girl this thrilling
miniseries about an English actor is
hired to infiltrate an assassin
terrorist cell is based on the novel of
the same name and fun fact it was
previously done as a 1984 feature film
starring Diane Keaton critics praised it
certified fresh' show for its
extraordinary art direction and a
uniformly terrific cast that includes
florence peu alexander skarsgård and the
great michael shannon this one is an
easy bin to just 5 and a half hours and
did I mention Michael Shannon is in it
and our throwback pick this week goes to
the consistently fresh drama alias this
show is executive produced by JJ Abrams
and ran on ABC for
2001 to 2006 and cemented Jennifer
Garner as a badass leading lady for her
portrayal of international spy Sydney
Bristow alias has an average audience
score of 85% and critics love the
dazzling action sequences fine writing
and believable characters if you get
through all five seasons and the seventy
three and a half hours of binging the
next step is to check out Jennifer
Garner's pretend cooking show on her
Instagram page seriously the soft
pretzel episode is so good
and finally our editors pick this week
goes to Marvel's Jessica Jones with
three fresh seasons this drama stars
Kristen Ritter as a PTSD stricken
superhero who hangs up her costume and
opens her own detective agency with the
supporting cast that includes carrie
anne moss and rachael taylor plus mike
colter Luke Cage popping in critics call
this a multi-faceted drama that's built
around its engaging antihero the third
and final season wrapped up last year
bringing the total bench time to just
over 36 hours for what could very well
be Marvel's strongest TV franchise all
right friends hopefully this will help
you kill your next to you binge session
be sure to let us know what you're
currently streaming in the comment
section and to check back for more
recommendations and ideas based around
the movies and shows that you love also
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and notification valve and thank
you so much for watching the Rotten
Tomatoes binge guys bye
[Music]
you